DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
The problem I'd like to work
with you right now is we
have a line which goes
through two points that
are given to us
explicitly, and we
have a plane which is
given to us by an equation.
And what we want to know
is where does this line
intersect this plane?
And so one thing I would
suggest to get started
is we need to give a
parametrization of our line
to get started.
OK, so why don't you work
on that, pause the tape,
and we'll come back in a moment
and work it out together.
OK, welcome back.
Let's get started.
So let's start off by
drawing a cartoon of what's
going on here.
So we have this plane
sitting in space.
And we have some line kind
of going through space.
So maybe it's like this.
And there's this single
point of intersection.
So even from the cartoon,
we can kind of, sort of
see two things
which are going on.
Which is that we would expect
a point of intersection,
or we would expect
exactly one, if we
choose kind of a generic
line and generic plane.
In order for there to be
no points of intersection,
we would have to
have a line which
was parallel to the plane,
which is very unlikely.
And then otherwise,
we expect exactly
just one point of intersection.
So I want to break this
sort of into two components.
So we have an equation
for the plane.
And when I see an equation
describing a plane,
I think of that as a sort
of test for membership.
We can plug in a point
(x, y, z) to the equation,
and we can ask, does this
point make the equation
true, or doesn't it?
And if it does, then that point
(x, y, z) is in the plane,
and otherwise it's
not in the plane.
For the line, what we're going
to need to do in a second is
we're going to need to come
up with a parametrization.
And a parametrization
is a different kind
of thing than an equation
describing a line.
A parametrization, rather than
being a test for membership,
is really a way of listing
all the points on the line.
So when we give a
parametrization-- in a second--
then we're going
to be able to list
all the points in the line.
And then we're going
to be able to plug
our list into the
equation for the plane,
and find out which point on our
list is actually in the plane.
Which one satisfies the
membership equation.
So why don't we
get started first
with parametrizing the line.
So the general kind
of picture here
is we have a point P_1 in space,
and we have another point P_2
in space, and we want to
parametrize the line which
goes between them.
And there's actually a
very simple way to do this.
What we do is we want to
take our original point P_1,
and we want to add a variable t
times the vector P_2 minus P_1
which connects them.
So that's this one here.
OK.
So this is a reasonable thing
to do, because if we plug in t
equals 0, then we just get P_1.
And if we plug in
t equals 1, then
we get P_1 plus P_2 minus
P_1; we just get P_2.
So this line definitely goes
through those two points,
and that's all that
we really need.
So in our specific
problem here, we
have-- P_1 we can take to be
the first point, 0, minus 1, 1.
And then we have t times--
so we have 2 minus 0 is 2-- 3
minus a negative 1 is
4-- and 3 minus 1 is 2.
And this is the vector
connecting those.
And so we can write, we
can just combine these two
and we get 2t, 4t
minus 1, and 2t plus 1.
OK?
So this here is a
parametrization of the line.
So as we vary t-- now, walking
back over to our picture--
as we vary t,
we're going to just
be listing all the
points on the line.
And we're going to
ask, for which point
are we actually
contained in the plane?
So let's go over to the board
over here and solve that.
So what we want to know is does
this point satisfy the equation
for the plane?
And our plane was given to us by
the equation 2x plus y minus z
equals 1.
So x on our line is 2t.
So we have 2 times 2t,
plus-- y is 4t minus 1,
minus-- z is 2t plus 1.
And all this is
meant to equal 1.
OK.
So if we expand this out, we
get 4t plus another 4t minus 2t
and we get minus 1 minus
another 1-- so we get minus 2--
equals 1.
So altogether we
get 6t equals 3,
so that tells us that t is 1/2.
OK?
And finally, to
get our answer, we
need to go back over to our
parametrization of the line
and plug in t equals 1/2.
So coming back over here,
plugging in t equals 1/2,
we get 1-- 2 minus 1 is
1-- and 1 plus 1 is 2.
OK, so we get the point of
intersection, (1, 1, 2).
So that was quite a few steps,
so let's review what we did.
So to begin with, we
needed to understand
that the equation for a plane
is a test for membership.
It's not a list of all
the points in the plane,
it's a test for membership.
The parametrization of the
line, on the other hand,
is a way of listing all
of the points on the line.
And so if our goal
is to find which
particular point on the line
is contained in the plane,
then we need to
parametrize our line,
and then we need to plug
in our parametrization
to our equation for
the plane, and then
solve for the value of
t which makes it true.
Finding that t then we've--
that's is equivalent to finding
a point on our line.
And I think I'll
leave it at that.